دعت وزيره الخارجيه سلوفانيا تانيا بايون
الى وقف فوري ودائم لاطلاق النار في غزه
وقالت في مقابله مع الجزيره ان الارقام
التي تاتي من غزه عن الضحايا المدنيين لا
تطاق ولا
تصدق سلوفينيا عبرت مرارا عن قلقها بشان
الوضع الصعب خلال جلسات مجلس الامن اكثر
من
23 مدني بينهم 9000 طفل فقدوا حياتهم هذا
امر لا يطاق وهذه الارقام لا تصدق ندعو
الى وقف فوري ودائم لاطلاق النار من المهم
جدا ان يتم ايصال المساعدات لمن يحتاج
اليها ليس هناك كهرباء ولا دواء ولا ماء
فهذا يعني ان الوضع الصحي مروع نحاول مع
المجتمع الدولي ان نقول ان هذا خرق جدي
للقانون الدولي الانساني وحقوق الانسان
ندعو كل الاطراف لحمايه هذه
القوانين وفي مقابله مع الجزيره قالت
وزاره وزيره الخارجيه السلوفينيه تانيا
فاين ايضا ان بلادها لم تقرر بعد ما اذا
كانت ستنضم الى الدعوه القضائيه المرفوعه
لدى محكمه العدل الدوليه من قبل جنوب
افريقيا ضد اسرائيل وقالت ان سلوفينيا
تتابع مسار القضيه وانها مستعده لتقديم
المساعده والاستشاره
القانونيه
نتابع النقاشات في القضيه التي رفعتها
جنوب افريقيا وفي الوقت الحالي لم نتخذ اي
اجراء للانضمام لاي من الاطراف لكن علينا
ان نرى ما الذي ستقرره المحكمه وكيف
ستتعامل مع القضيه وبعد ذلك سنقدم حجتنا
القانونيه كي نقرر اذا ما كنا سننظم الى
الدعوه ام لا ولكن استطيع القول ان
سلوفينيا كانت في الماضي الى جانب المسائل
وبتالي نحن مستعدون لتقديم الاستشاره
القانونيه والمساعده في هذه القضيه كما
حدث في قضايا اخرى في فلسطين واوكرانيا في
حال ارتكاب فضائع خلال الحروب